when in the course of human events it
becomes necessary for one people to
dissolve the political bands which have
connected them with another and to
assume among the powers of the earth the
separate and equal station to which the
laws of nature and of nature's God and
tell them respect to the opinions of
mankind requires that they should
declare the causes which impel them to
the separation we hold these truths to
be self-evident that all men are created
equal but they're endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness that to secure
these rights governments are instituted
among men deriving their just powers
from the consent of the governed that
whenever any form of government becomes
destructive of these ends it is the
right of the people to alter or abolish
it and to institute new government
laying its foundation on such principles
and organizing its powers in such form
as to them shall seem most likely to
effect their safety prudence indeed will
dictate that governments long
established should not be changed for
light or transient causes and
accordingly all experience has shown
that mankind are more disposed to suffer
while evils are sufferable than to right
themselves by abolishing the form to
which they are accustomed but with a
long train of abuses and usurpations
pursuing invariably the same object
evinces a design to reduce them under
absolute despotism it is their right it
is their duty to throw off such
government and to provide new guards for
their future security we therefore the
representatives of the United States of
America appealing to the supreme judge
of the world for the rectitude of our
intentions do in the name and by the
authority of the good people of these
colonies solemnly publish and declare
that these United colonies are
and a right ought to be free and
independent states that they are
absolved from all allegiance to the
British crown and that all political
connection between them and the state of
Great Britain is and ought to be totally
dissolved and that is free and
independent states they have full power
to levy war conclude peace contract
alliances establish Commerce and to do
all other acts and things which
Independent States may of right do and
for the support of this declaration with
a firm reliance on the protection of
divine providence we mutually pledge to
each other our lives and fortunes and
our sacred honor
you